welcome back to grammar with me Josh
Smith and boro it must be cold in here
I've got two honey's I'm in the
atmosphere it's Jessica Alba Gabrielle
Union how are you oh good
now LA finest I'm loving it
your ass-kicking you asked whooping your
high kicking bad ass girls but for you
is 2019 how surprising was the script TA
it's not really surprising like we've
been we've been he's wanted yeah yeah
maybe surprising for others but we're
like baby
yeah what's been the hardest thing for
you guys in terms of the hurdles you've
had to get over to get to this point you
think I think 20 years of having to
prove yourself over and over and over
and over and over and over and over
again and getting executives comfortable
with the idea that they can bank on us
racism misogyny toxic masculinity on a
lack of accountability lack of
transparency people loving the idea of
diversity and inclusion but not actually
making it a Rebecca set oh you know
those small spaces small things yeah you
are kind of fighting against toxic
masculinity in this narrative as well in
some ways like when you come up against
that in your own lies how do you react
to it and how do you shut it down I'm
not gonna be polite and smile i'ma tell
you to your face
but the goal is to create an atmosphere
for men and women on set for of all
different shapes sizes ethnicities
languages to feel happy safe and
productive and seen and valued so how
you guys trying to combat against
everyday sexism and what kind of
everyday sexism do you still have to
deal with all of it it's weird that pop
culture is actually always at the
forefront of progress because people
have to see it first play out until
they're comfortable with the idea of it
and we do know that we live in a bubble
in entertainment and in Hollywood
because it is quite progressive what
have you guys learnt about the powerful
sisterhood
working on they say in our own personal
lives we both have really strong
friendships with women I feel like there
has been such a lack of that type of
representation of female friendship
what kind of love do you want to build
for your children would you say I want
them to be able to be seen in their
fullness and appreciated in their
fullness and for people to see their
Worth and their value that is the goal
and for every child in this global
village to feel like their lives and
their very breath holds the same weight
how awful the whole immigration thing is
happening and children are being locked
in cages and separated from their family
still it's it's atrocious our laws
aren't there to protect our children I
think that is something that we as
parents have to continue to fight to
make sure that our kids feel safe and
protected so they don't have to worry
about going to school and so there's
there are things about humanity that are
all being sort of questioned and
offended in our country then hopefully
we're creating a world where that
happens